who among you do you concede is the most
attractive is there just a general
acceptance that one of you was more
attractive than the other is the overall
consensus of sexiness yeah just about
what you like some people like pork
chops
some people like Tebow you know some
people some people like a steak and I
could get it that Chris is the pork chop
yeah he likes pork chops I like it's not
the most ordered item huh
people love the steak steak they love
the lean meat well I think the marbling
that tastes good you know dim lights you
like a little fatty are you comparing
our bodies to food items different
saying that some yes who is the most
attractive and it's like you know it's
like saying what's the best thing on the
menu basically with beef cakes you go to
a barbecue you might want a little bit
of salmon you know you might worsen are
you suddenly the one with the most omega
fatty acid to enjoy okay sound like the
part where the poop comes out of the
cabin so you would then be used to be
you were the only used to be you were
the only woman on the set and this was
the only conversation was men comparing
themselves to get all beat all the time
[Laughter]
that's the healthy go yeah you give a
high-fiber geez you taste better with
brown sugar butter
with me I've been this by the way
relax this doesn't air this is I got a
signal about five minutes ago that this
wasn't gonna end so now you should just
enjoy yourself the point I was trying to
make is that in thor ragnarok they rip
your eye off and they mess up your hair
and still you seem to be as handsome
which enrages me it doesn't that is that
not the trimming it gorges you I think
you got the word wrong well it was I
knew that there was a feeling of
excitement and a real high level of
something yeah yeah you might have been
stuck stay with me yeah the fatty meat
[Laughter]
arable it's on these are there's like
eight billion dollars worth of towel in
the room and it's uh narrable I take
responsibility for that publicists are
just rushing out of the room
you